ihre kchefin Alis Weidel im Bundestag
die der Bundesregierung vorwirft sie
hassen dieses Land sie auch so sehen ja
zumindestens liebt sie dieses Land nicht
so wie die Bundesregierung so wie die
Bundesregierung
agier ist sicherlich Überspitzung
einiger Aussagen finden Sie das gut wenn
man so redet wenn Sie das so in diesem
Moment empfindet und das war sicherlich
eine Empfindung von Frau Weidel es war
sehr war sehr Z war aufgeschrieben das
war sehr bewusst vorgetragen auch sehr
sehr sehr mit empase das war völlig klar
manche politischen Entscheidung die ich
sehe und wie die politische Regierung
oder die Regierung aktuell agiert jaich
kann man das sagen und sehen dass dieses
Land aktuell von Politikern regiert wird
die mit Deutschland wenig am Hut haben